I would like to come from a different
perspective. I'm not a theologian.
I'm just a regular Muslim girl born and
raised, but I come from a Christian
background. [clears throat]
I don't get it. If she was born and
raised a Muslim, what's her Christian
background?
That kind of threw me off.
I'm a Muslim born and raised. So, what
Christian background? You didn't come
from a Christian background, right? If
you're born raised, are you saying your
family? Okay, anyway.
>> We deal with logic
for us. Mhm. And
God says in the Bible and in the Quran
he is not the author of confusion.
So, religion or God should be simple
enough for 5-year-old. You guys want me
to shish kebab that misapplication of 1
Corinthians 14:33?
We're going to have fun today.
She goes that God is not the God of
confusion, right? That's 1 Corinthians
14:33.
Meaning if God's nature is confusing,
it cannot be true. Keep that in mind.
Now, she is referring to 1 Corinthians
14:33.
Right?
You guys see why you guys laughing, huh?
Cuz she goes we deal logic. Yeah, well,
they are dealing with logic, lady logic.
What's wrong with you haters?
They're dealing with lady logic. to
understand the concept. When you start
adding layers and layers and layers, it
not only confuses a 5-year-old, but a
full-grown adult. And I believe that God
sent us here to search for him and
search for the truth. All of us, Muslim,
Christian,
Jew.
Um but as far as the Trinity is
concerned, it is not mentioned in the
Bible once.
Uh not once. But it is mentioned in the
Quran.
Um Okay, let's stop there. No, it's not.
Guys, we're going to have fun, man. I
didn't know I'm hearing it for the first
time. Okay, remember
10 minute 21 second mark. You ready for
the meat?
You guys learn your Bible.
You ready for me?
Here's they're going TO CATCH YOU. AHA!
AHA! [screaming] WE GOT YOU, SAMMY.
FOR GOD IS NOT A GOD OF CONFUSION, but
of peace.
As in all the churches of the saints. We
got you, Sammy.
We got you.
THAT'S IT. IT'S OVER.
TRINITY CAN'T BE BIBLICAL, SAMMY.
All right. But, I'm thankful they bring
it up. You know, this is one of the
first verses that was brought up against
me.
Number one, do you know what the context
is? It has nothing to do with the nature
of God. We're going to start at 25.
We're going to read uh 2
38. Now, by the way,
the entire context is about
propriety in worship.
Okay, you're listening?
Propriety in worship.
Yep, you're going to have shish kebab,
brother.
Paul is addressing chaos in the church.
Exactly, brother.
PROTESTANT BELIEVER. LEBIANO, WHERE
ARE YOU, MAN? Me and Jay want to team UP
WITH YOU. BINGO! [screaming]
ALL RIGHT. ANYWAY,
PAUL IS addressing propriety in the
church. If you read this chapter 14,
read it tonight. Prayerfully read it.
He's dealing with chaos in the church.
Why?
His first concern is the scenario of
chapter 14. There are people bursting
out praying in tongues
that no one understands
leading to confusion and chaos.
And Paul has to rebuke and reprimand
them. He spends most of the chapter
talking about, "Buddy,
I'd rather pray five intelligible words.
Pray with my mind with words
that everyone understands and I
understand than 10,000 words in my
spirit that nobody understands. Why?
Because prayer is not just for your
edification.
Prayer is for the edification blessing
of the church. Don't be selfish.
When you pray in tongues,
you're edifying your inner person, your
spirit, but no one else is being
edified.
But when you pray clearly
and people understand your words, you
bless them, you move them, you convict
them. Isn't that the truth?
Isn't that the truth?
How many times have you heard prayers
that are articulated clearly, moved you
to tears, moved you
to deeper passion? That's the kind of
here. I'm not lying, man.
Then he addresses
other issues.
People
standing up out of turn,
prophesying, meaning proclaiming God's
word cuz there are prophets at this time
that God's spirit will give them
revelation.
Out of turn and then unruly wives
interrupting the congregation to ask
questions out of turn. It became a whole
mess.
People talking out of turn, people
interrupting.
Right here.
See?
Whole chapter. I'm not lying.
It's in this context that he says, "God
is not a god of confusion." Meaning,
"God does not inspire chaos."
Why are you chaotic, confusing,
where all of you speak out of turn, no
one follows order?
Right? Someone's cutting someone off.
No one's being edified and it's leading
to arguments. See?
It's all all that. I'm not lying.
See?
So, let's see what the context is,
right?
See how beautiful it is when someone
shows you context? But, what is this
teaching you Christians?
Why do you let someone quote a verse of
the Bible
without going back to the Bible and
seeing the context?
God is not the God of confusion. Excuse
me,
where are you [clears throat] quoting
from?
I bet you she didn't know.
What's the context?
>> [clears throat]
>> So, here
it's saying, "When you speak in
languages, one of the purpose is to
convince people who are not believers
that when they see you speak in
languages, they will know this is a move
of God, an act of God, and they will
fall and worship of the God that
energized you to speak in languages."
See that?
So, he will fall on his face
and worship God, declaring
"That surely God is among you." But, now
let's see the context, shall we?
Okay, you guys want to see the context?
You want to learn?
Are you enjoying this? This is why I'm
doing it, cuz it will let me know not
only talk about Trinity, but practical
application. How to pray, how not to
pray, how to conduct yourself. May we
all practice what we preach.
I pray that for myself, so I don't fall
short.
Here you go.
>> [clears throat]
>> 26. What is the outcome then, brothers?
When you assemble,
each one has a song. See, each one of
you
want to sing a song,
or has a teaching,
or has a revelation, or has a tongue,
being moved to pray in
a language, and someone has the ability
to translate it. But, now watch.
Here's the rule. He began it here.
Pursue love.
Whatever you do,
do it out of love for God, love for one
another. Don't do it out of selfishness.
Don't do it out of
status.
Don't do out of
envy or position or fame or fortune. You
understand? Everything you do, brothers
and sisters,
must be done out of the love of God.
Your love for God and because you love
God, love for the church. You must do it
out of love. Not because you want to be
famous.
Not because you want to be popular. Not
because you want to be the standard. Not
out of ego because you want money.
You see it right there? Pursue love.
You see how he starts it?
In fact, even before he got here, look
what he said.
What's the greatest love of gift of all?
Watch her.
But [clears throat] now abide, faith,
hope, and love.
These three, but the greatest of these
is love. Notice,
he mentions love being greater than
faith and hope.
And then he starts the chapter or the
new discussion. Sorry.
Okay, are we learning this?
Tell you what say you jumped on my
YouTube, huh? All right. I thought you
were on Rumble.
David, everyone got it?
Okay. Now, let's see the context.
All right. Let all these things
>> [clears throat]
>> be done for edification.
Meaning you're doing it to build each
other.
To strengthen each other. To cause each
other to be more holy, more obedient,
more faithful. I have no doubt.
God is real.
If anyone speaks in a tongue, it should
be two or at the most three. This is the
order.
And each in turn,
but one [clears throat] must translate.
You know how many churches violate this?
Do you know how many churches violate
this?
Pentecostal churches, they don't follow
this. You hear them all breaking out in
tongues.
And then if you try to tell them, "But
my brother, but Paul was clear, wasn't
he?"
No, but that's a prayer language. I'm
praying to yourself. Yeah, but Paul was
talking about praying. If you're praying
tongues and I don't understand, you're
not edifying anybody.
He goes, "I'm not even edifying my mind
cuz I don't even know what I'm saying.
My spirit is being edified."
Right?
>> [cough]
[clears throat]
>> See that?
So, no more than three, but you must
have a translator. Now watch. But if
there's no translator,
he must keep silent in the church. Let
him speak to himself and to God. Why are
you praying aloud?
You see are you preaching the deep dive?
Why are you praying aloud?
>> [clears throat]
>> Sorry guys, it's uh hair in Jesus' name
heal me of these
infections in the almighty name of
Jesus.
All right.
Okay.
Now, [clears throat]
when it comes to prophets,
in Jesus' name crush Satan by the blood
of Christ. See, sitting here kills my
throat.
But if there's no translator, you must
be silent. Now,
two or three prophets speak
and let the others pass judgment.
Two or three, but if a revelation is
made to another who's seated,
the first one must keep silent. See what
the the context is? So, if I get a
revelation
because I'm
a prophet.
Silent, I got to speak.
Now, watch here though.
This is when they gathered together,
brother.
This is when they came to church.
Their structure evolved and developed
so you have to take into consideration
development.
Okay, now watch.
>> [clears throat]
>> Revelation is made to one another who is
seated. The first one is keep silent.
For you can all prophesy one by one so
that all may learn and all may be
exhorted.
And the spirits of the prophets are
subject for you know what it means here?
You are empowered,
>> [clears throat]
>> energized by God
to be in control
of your emotions
so that you don't need to break out
in a tongue or a revelation because the
spirit in you energizes you to control
yourself.
>> [snorts]
>> Right?
Do you understand this right here or no?
You cannot break out an ecstatic frenzy
out of control like some of the people
do in churches where they break out and
they start laughing hysterically or
throwing themselves on the floor,
barking.
That's
that's a joke.
Because he just told you
the
God you worship
empowers, energizes you by the Holy
Spirit to control your spirit, your
emotions, and not be controlled by them.
1 Corinthians 14, buddy.
See that?
Here is now the passage she quoted. For
God is not a god of confusion, but of
peace, as in all the churches.
Now, he that's the context. What has
that got to do with the nature of God?
What does this got to do with the nature
of God being complex?
It's saying God is not a god of
disorder.
He doesn't inspire chaos, confusion.
And let's finish and I'll show you the
Greek and then
we'll see what Paul says about the
nature of God.
The women are to keep silent in
churches. Now, before you jump the gun,
before you jump the gun,
he's not talking about shut up,
be quiet, cuz he uses the same word
here.
The prophet must be silent when someone
else has given the word to prophesy.
You see it here?
What [clears throat] woman is he saying
be silent? You ready?
Are you ready for the context?
What woman
does he have in mind that need to be
silent?
The women who are are to keep silent in
churches, for they're not permitted to
speak, but are to subject themselves
just as the law also says.
But if they desire to learn anything,
let them ask their own husbands at home,
for it is a disgraceful for women to
speak in church. Now, if you take Paul
out of context, you're thinking women
can't do anything. That's not true.
Paul has earlier said at 1 Corinthians
11:4-5,
women are allowed to pray and prophesy
in the church
as long as they have the sign of a
submission and do it the authority of
the bishop. He's talking about chaos.
He's addressing a situation in the
church in Corinth.
The women here are the women that are
acting out of turn,
disrupting the service, asking
questions, right? Creating chaos. And
it's not just any woman, but these women
were married. See why you got to read
carefully?
Are all women married?
No.
Do you understand Paul is addressing a
situation in the church?
When you don't know the historical
context,
you don't know the situation, you're
going to think these are blanket
statements referring to all women. No.
He just told you, I'm talking about the
married women. Married women where? At
Corinth.
What were they doing? Disrupting.